this is a production of Cornell
University
so you have not accidentally wandered
into an entomology talk this is actually
a horticultural talk but because it's an
insect that affects a lot of potential
plants um it's something that I thought
people would be a would it be of
interest to the horticulture seminar
group
I'm also and Nina noticed I actually do
have a doorstep on my pick a picture of
a doorstep so we'll get to that and
explain it a little bit more so I'm
gonna ask you questions to start out cuz
you know it's lunchtime and I have to
keep everybody awake how many people
have already heard of spotted Lantern
fly very good how many of you are from
Pennsylvania if that helps okay so
that's a start all right are there
spotted Lantern fly populations in New
York State at the moment yes okay so we
have some yeses in some noes good we'll
cover that
what's the host range you can shout out
anything that that's a pretty good
answer so far as far as we know so far
and is there anything we should be doing
about it yes that's that's always a good
answer there's almost always yes we
should be doing something about it and
then is there any good news iíll answer
that one I think the answer is yes yep
CRISPR oh I haven't heard about that so
you could bring that up at the end so is
that the answer he gives to everything
so if you haven't heard of it it's
spotted Lantern fly as a plant hopper
it's from China and it has moved across
the universe actually just the world and
even came in they believe on stones egg
masses came in on stone brought from
Korea I think as far as they understand
he was introduced to Korea about the
same time it was introduced to the
United States which is around 200 2014
so you can see it is a beautiful insect
if you happen to like insects let's see
do I have a pointer I don't know oops
that's always a bad thing to do I won't
do that again one of the things I want
you to note though is the size markers
and you can see it's not the actual size
is not this big but it is a half an inch
and I'm going to pass these around these
are not great but they at least show you
how big the insect is that we're talking
so yeah don'ts about the don'ts about an
inch you notice that when they fly into
you they're pretty big and they don't
they do fly they also hop they're good
hoppers their planners so I'm gonna talk
a little bit about it but you'll see
this kind of picture gets put out a lot
because one of the things we're most
interested in is that people are looking
for it and identifying it so if it does
occur in New York State you'll know
about it so there's the here's the
answer to that first question does are
they're spotted Lantern fly populations
in New York State at the moment as far
as we know you know scientists we have
to qualify everything there are no
existing populations in the state but if
you look at all these orange spots those
are all times that has been found for
example Monroe County they found at
least 37 in an order of Christmas trees
that were brought up from Pennsylvania
cut Christmas trees it was first
identified actually in Dutchess County
and it was in a pharmaco pharmacology
pharmacological warehouse somebody
noticed it and that's when they first
that's first time they found it in New
York State so it was introduced in right
around here in Pennsylvania and it has
spread since 2014 that looks pretty bad
like it's spreading it's continuing to
spread and it is every time I go and
look for this management website I have
to keep making it it's bigger it takes
up more space because it keeps adding
more states for locations either where
its existing populations blue or yellow
where they found it and not not a
population so it looks bad but the thing
to me that's absolutely amazing it's it
is not yet there is no no no nations yet
in New York State and everyone assumed
that we would get it last summer that we
would have it last summer we don't have
it yet what does that say to you what's
it well not that because you're right
that the winters are cold enough to kill
the adults they're not cold enough to
kill the egg nests what it means to me
is we've done a good job of keeping an
eye out for it and preventing it from
coming in so in Pennsylvania is doing a
ton of work and are very generous and
sharing
with us so not yet in New York State so
it's not here why should we talk about
it start looking at the numbers and
losses from Pennsylvania will give you
an indication of why we'd like to keep
it out as long as possible and also be
ready for it when it gets here
so the AG AG department so 18 million
dollars in plant based commodities in
the state that doesn't include homeowner
business tourism losses Pennsylvania has
added three billion to their state
budget to control it they have I think
four full-time hotline people but to
answer calls when people call that they
are recording it or that they they want
to know if they found it they also the
problem that people are calling 9-1-1 so
they have really have ads out that say
please don't call 9-1-1 for spotted
lanterns line they also have a lot of
you can get spotted land reply earrings
socks all sorts of things so it is a
beautiful so one of the things is why is
it such a problem it's easy to kill with
pesticides it's a little hard to catch
them they're good jumpers does this
picture give you any idea why they might
be there as the egg masses in particular
are hard to see the adults are pretty
easy to see but look at the numbers it
occurs in huge numbers I have never seen
insects that mass like that it would
seem contouring contraindicated that you
know they're all sharing the same flow
of source so they're all competing with
each other but they are very happy
together
unfortunately so what's one thing that
you notice from this picture with it
apple trees in it the tree looks fine
the leaves are still okay what really
looks fine the fruit they don't feed on
the fruit they feed in the woody tissue
so they're feeding in the phloem so
they're set and they're really they look
this picture little kind of malevolence
these are not actually their eyes their
eyes are up there but the orange and
orange spots make them look like they're
really dangerous but look at the mouth
parts I don't know if you can see with
the lights on but the mouth parts go
right into the twig but this twig is a
lot woodier then you're going to see
usual plant hoppers feeding on so
they're big they're strong enough to
get their mouthparts into that woody
tissue and then they tap into the flow
they don't actually have very much of a
suction but it just kind of sort of
moves through them pretty pretty easily
and the moving through is another issue
I would have pregnant so they produce a
huge amount of honeydew oh that's much
better thank you so if you look at this
bottom step that's the one they've
cleaned off the other two still have the
honeydew on them and if you think about
that number of insects in a tree you can
imagine that there's a lot of honeydew
see if they can make this work so they
have swarm feeding again they're not
really feeding there's someone on the
fruit but they're not actually attached
it's the ones that aren't moving much
and you can see this one up here there's
some you can see their mouthparts but
look at that that's the honeydew sorting
out it's like a squirt gun so when
you're talking about and that's just one
with that mass of them they're I mean
underneath you can see and then you get
City mold developing in them in this in
the honeydew so it can actually help
kill some plants so this is a vineyard
in Pennsylvania and you can see the the
vines here don't look very happy and our
dead actually what they think is the
feeding on the plants affected them
enough that winter that than they were
winter killed so it wasn't that the
insects directly killed them but they
led to their demise and they they do fly
and they move from feeding site to
feeding site so this looks like I
photoshopped spotted Lantern fly in
there but actually it's a clip from a
video and all those things that look
kind of like birds are actually and
they're moving either into or out of
this at large so it's big there's lots
of them and it can move itself around
and also isn't very fussy where it lays
eggs again from the point of view of
development of an insect it seems very
odd to put your eggs on something they
can't feed on but they like rusty metal
and if this this is at the bottom of a
planter so if you you know your great
aunt Agatha gave you a planter to take
back from Pennsylvania you would
necessarily think that that's something
you needed to remove it looks like money
and that's what they do they cover their
eggs so here's egg masses the eggs are
laid and they cover them with kind of
this muddy substance and it dries and
turns of darker Brown and looks very
much like bark so here's somebody
scraping them we'll talk about that in a
minute
but they lay them on anything that's
outside and they lay a lot of egg masses
all at the same time and one or other
people other their people other spotted
lanterns I seem to lay them again in the
same location and it's a really good
hitchhiker so can you see the numbers
here on this tire now at least on the
tire many of them will be run over but
not all of them and so they seem to they
do everything in a group they're not
very they're not great individualist
they're doing everything together so if
you've got numbers like that trying to
make sure that you've cleaned them all
off a vehicle before it goes anywhere is
tough so if you think about this
location here's Philadelphia think about
the transportation that goes through
Philadelphia it's amazing and a lot of
it comes door and it comes into New York
State so this actually is another clip
from a video but there's a spotted
lantern fly on a tree there's the Train
and if you think about the kind of area
around train tracks
nobody's managing it very much so it's
and it was going pretty slowly it would
be easy enough for a spotted lantern
flag adult to hop on and find a place
where it didn't get blown off and move
in fact the reason I said in boats too
is there was a boat that came from
Philadelphia Harbor into New York and it
was quarantined before I was allowed to
land but to dock because they found
spotted Lantern flight on the boat and
they had to they had to clean it up
before they would let it dock so it can
come in lots of ways it's very easy for
it to hide in places I think with the
Christmas trees what we think is they
actually liked that the adults were all
dead but they seem to crawl into the
wrapping so they also seem to like to be
in sort of tight places which also makes
it harder to find them so okay are you
all scared now it's it was in the that's
the reason to why we believe it is
definitely coming
so here's the why here's about the host
range and I think this is what we know
and every time I see a list it's got
more things on it
at first it was mostly trees and shrubs
now we're seeing things like basil and
cucumbers and soybeans and status and
lots and lots of other things but
there's also this difference between
what it's feeding on and what it's
laying its eggs on it lays its eggs on
lots of stuff so we have had one case of
an egg mass coming in on nursery stock
into Long Island we had as well as we've
had I'm sure we've had other cases of
things coming in that's the one that
I've heard of but so the Christmas trees
you don't see anything that's what we
use is Christmas trees on this host
range list but it will lay its eggs on
Christmas tree bark and that's one thing
we're worried about because who's
looking for the egg masses hopefully the
growers are but once they're in this so
once you have them you bring it in your
house actually would be an advantage if
the egg mass would hatch it would freak
people out and we'd hear screaming so I
don't think it's happened yet but the
problem is you keep it in your house a
little bit of time and then you throw it
out now you've got an egg mass that's
sitting outside the eggs aren't killed
by the cold and they will hatch out at
some point
so the feeding the feeding versus
egg-laying has some importance both for
moving it around and then also for the
damage that's likely likely to call
cause so even where pebbles are one of
the more or less preferred hosts part of
the problem is not that they're feeding
on the maple but that they're dropping
honeydew down below and it's in
landscape settings so they dothey we
know a little bit about them Tree of
Heaven is a preferred host as it showed
before that's that's we think it's
required a required host we also think
that's the reason that they things don't
eat them because they acquire a toxin
from feeding on Tree of Heaven so they
don't taste good and if you saw the
picture of the insect I'm gonna give you
an entomology quiz now what's the one
thing about the picture of the insect
which might let you believe that it
doesn't taste good it's red yep so
they're red so Tree of Heaven they seem
to be on anytime grapes they seem to be
on anytime both wild and cultivated
grape but there is a preference for
fourth instar through adults for the
Tree of Heaven so it makes it one
advantage on that is that you can use
Tree of Heaven as a place to go scout
potentially treat the insect and they've
they're seeing that they sort of move
over time so on some things like rows
you find the nymphs but you don't see
the adults there and there seems to be
some preference for the late-season
adults for things like silver maple and
Willow so again everything that we know
we know a little bit and we may find out
more information as I said the
Pennsylvania Pennsylvania they're doing
a lot of research on it we're not doing
quite so much here because we don't have
it and we don't want to bring it in
there is some research that's going on
in New York State though so what should
we be doing about it
learn to identify it is the first thing
that's kind of why I'm doing this
presentation one is many of you had
heard about it would you have been able
to identify it before I gave the talk
got some nodding and we've got some know
so at least there's a reason to do this
talk so we're learning to identify and
looking for it is one thing that we can
do doing in New York State so again the
life stages they're big and they're
beautiful and that maybe helps I don't
know but it's the egg masses that I
think are the hard part to find just
because they're meant to be cryptic and
again I think I showed you so you can
see the eggs and then they get covered
with the mud and then the mud often
turns brown they you won't find all
stages all the time so the life cycle
has some importance in terms of
identifying it and looking for it to
know what you're looking for so eggs are
there for a long time they actually
start laying eggs in September and they
can be there all the way through June so
that's before they start hatching out
then you get the first instars hatching
out in the spring and you don't get
forth in stars and the adults until and
then the adults it shows that it says
July to December they are killed by the
cold temperatures but if it's warm
enough they will stick around that long
so this is based on Pennsylvania so it's
going to be similar to what we would see
here we think but there's always just
enough difference that's one of them
good nose points that I'll get to at the
end so what to look for honey do wasps
and bees feeding on the honey do the
black city mold on the honey do you can
actually see this is a terrible slide
but there's a group of spotted lantern
fly here in this trunk and then you can
see that it's
so that's again will help you do get
some flight and get flagging on the
branches but of course we get flagging
on branches for other reasons so you
need to go look to make sure that this
flagging is actually caused by spotted
lanterns life can most time us turn and
all of a sudden that sounds very loud so
hopefully I'm not blasting interview up
now if you're looking for information on
identification or lots of other pieces
New York State IPM has a lot on our
website and we're one of the partners in
the in New York State sort of plan of
attack for spotted lantern fly and so as
I said the most current map is always on
our website and there's other things
anytime something comes up it usually
gets added here and then we create some
of it also
so NYS IPM that Cornell dot edu that's
us sorry NYS IPM at Cornell dd no extra
dot another thing that we can learn to
do is identify Tree of Heaven how many
people can identify tree of heaven I'm
glad to see the police should be able to
identify it how many of them do we have
some in the Botanic Gardens undoubtedly
there there are many many places and so
one of the things to look for when the
seeds are on it's pretty easy it's a
compound leaf so that's a little there
are some things other things that look
like it but very few things have this
little node so that's one of the
indicators it's also reported to smell
like rancid peanut butter rancid other
things feet I've heard so if you're out
walking around and you smell feet look
sinking tree so that's so that's one
thing is to identify where they are and
then map actually mapping them and if
you can get rid of them
that's a good thing too now this is a
nice specimen tree no one's going to not
very likely go out there and cut it down
so that one you may not take out if
they're if you're in a more wild area or
woody edges you might actually try and
remove them they are fairly hard to kill
you can't just cut them down as you'll
have more so they do what they call the
hack and squirt method where you cut
into essentially just under the bark and
then you apply the herbicide there and
that will kill the tree if you're going
to kill if you're only going to kill one
kill them female
but that's because they're producing
seeds and they're very good invasive and
they will grow more of trees from seeds
so if you can if you can get rid of the
females even if you leave the males
that's still an advantage and then
anything that's left is used as a place
to scout so because they have to be
there and especially when the adults are
out you can go look at those trees or
actually put sticky traps on those trees
to see if you're finding any spotted
lantern fly and so when they're when
they found it when we've had areas where
they found some they do a lot of this
around the areas it's go Scout the the
Tree of Heaven and do other things to
make sure that there is not a population
well that's again yes it was that going
to get rid of the problem know it but
because they tend to be an attractive
thing where it'll pull them in they
they're actually using them as trap
trees so you keep some and get rid of
the others and that way it makes it
easier you could treat the ones that are
left with a systemic pesticide and then
that's a way to and that seems to work
on controlling spotted lantern fly it's
a good way to get get the control with
using the least amount of pesticide also
so at this point I mean if if you can
get rid of some of them so that you're
not trying to you know having to scout
all of them that also helps yes its and
it's one thing to say that when we don't
have it yet it's like well I'll wait
till they get here then that's
understandable apparently they seem to
like that they are preferred and they
seem to have to feed on them so in
Alaska well I say that as far as we know
and so for example if you have them they
come into and there's maples around and
they're happy on the maples they may not
immediately move to the spot to the Tree
of Heaven so but it is in terms of a
place that they seem to require feeding
there that they will eventually end up
there so if you find anything that you
think might be spotted Lantern fly even
if you're not quite sure and you might
be wrong still scrape eggs into the
handset hand sanitizer alcohol if you
can catch the other stages put them in
alcohol or freeze them the nymphs and
the second and the fourth end stars just
run they don't jump so they're a little
bit easier to catch pretty fast though
and then you can send pictures and the
location information to
lantern fly at agriculture New York gov
some of the older information says Dec
because Dec was originally the spot to
send them to now it's the Department of
Ag and markets so now we also have an
external quarantine and what's like
what's a quarantine these days it has to
do with tour boats that's right in this
case we have an external quarantine
because we don't have them yet so what
we have is a quarantine that's that's
limiting access to movement of things
from someplace into New York so anywhere
that has a red line around that's
interesting there are some places that
they know they have populations that are
not yet in our quarantine but that
everyone is but most of Pennsylvania
most of the other sites it's some of
these areas of New Jersey that we're
kind of worried about cuz they're pretty
close and I think they've maybe found
some even closer to New York but so it's
an external quarantine that means that
you have to consider what's happened to
what's moving through that area any of
those areas into New York State so how
do you know where it is if you're in
Pennsylvania actually the Pennsylvania
Department of Agriculture has this
website if you look goo GLE them and and
put under put it in spotted lantern fly
in quarantine though there's a button
for an interactive map and the address
and it will pop up whether or not it's
in the quarantine zone or not so it's
like well that seems like kind of
overkill I'm just going on vacation but
you can bring them back from being on
vacation as well so that's actually
Brian our parents house so if you're a
commercial business and you're bringing
anything in not just if you're doing the
trucking but if anything is coming in
and again this Christmas tree issue is
one of them so if you're bringing in
anything the regulated articles include
all plants and plant parts any stage of
the insect and anything reasonably
believed to be infested with or
harboring that's like anything that
might be sitting outside vehicles
everything else and all plant parts and
any kind of any stage of the insect so
it's a broad it's a very broad
quarantine
sometimes in quarantines we say you
can't bring anything that would you know
like you can't bring this fruit in or
you can't bring this plant in if we did
this we would actually stop all commerce
because essentially
anything that's outside it could be on
so instead of saying you can't bring it
if you if you have any of those articles
you have to have a certificate of
inspection you have to have a way bill
with where it originated and where it's
supposed to be going and the companies
that you're buying from are supposed to
provide those and then you should know
something about how it was shipped and
loaded and everything else so again
there's the the link from for the
department and egged markets they have a
lot of information on this quarantine
but so this is an issue that does affect
New York growers and other people that
are bringing plant material so I've
already had a call from somebody growing
blueberries who wanted to know if it was
okay I don't even work on blueberries
but what I wanted to know if it was okay
to bring in blueberry plants from
Pennsylvania and I said well certainly
just inspect them make sure that they
he's like no I can't do it I have to get
them from Maine now so that's the small
example but I suspect that means that we
are seeing economic effects and we'll
see more as they come along this is one
on the d-o-t inspection spots so if you
can see that and they're stopping trucks
they're stopping they're starving
vehicles along the roads coming in from
Pennsylvania and actually inspecting
them if you have they have splatted the
spot Atlanta fly sniffing dogs also
which is pretty cool so if it's a
personal trip the thing is if you're
gonna be driving through the quarantine
zone don't stop if you don't have to if
you do look check your vehicle inside
and out they like to get inside cars for
some reason and I know someone was
scouting I was a scout that was writing
an article and they said yep they
stopped at the gas station and they were
just about to go into Maryland before it
was in Maryland and just look in their
trunk and one had climbed in the trunk
so they for some reason like like to go
visiting and if you're moving anything
that's been left outside inspected
especially for the egg masses so they're
starting to put out again documents like
this looking at the plants and plant
parts but looking at packing material
looking at landscape materials looking
anything that's the left outside and you
can even if you're a public citizen but
you happen to go in and out of
Pennsylvania a lot you can get a permit
it's pretty easy online trainings get
the permit if
I was people from Pennsylvania were
speaking for us and they said yeah they
had to make so many that they don't even
have nice plastic ones now they're just
paper cuz there were so many that the
people are requesting so are we ready in
New York State I think we are as ready
as we can be
they actually created something called
an incident command group just like a
like for battles where they brought in
all these collaborators egg and markets
Dec parks other people to say alright
what do you need to know what who's
doing what piece what do we need to know
and what do we need to do so we have
this concept of protective zones if they
found any stage that will make a
protective zone around it and check very
heavily to see if there are any
populations there they have the
checkpoints on the roads that we
actually do have lists of - double e
lists of pesticides already the labels
are already ready they're not out yet
because we don't have the insect but as
soon as the insect is determined to be
here then those will become available so
that it we don't do wait because it
often takes a little bit of time to get
a special special needs permit for our
license I'm sorry not license but label
for a pesticide so this way they're
already ready to go and they are looking
at those for secondary effects on
pollinators because we're trying not to
cause harm when the process of causing
good and then we're looking at this
concept of training for management
methods I have some handouts up here
that are from Pennsylvania that have a
lot of the information on how to manage
them and how to look for them and so
forth so if anyone's interested and
bumper stickers there's a lot of swag
Pennsylvania is doing as I said a lot of
research and they're sharing all of it
which is very very helpful so this is
one of their management calendars that
they've created but they're also doing
research on a lot of the different
things not just management methods but
biology and movement
what's it one of the effects on
different host insecticide trials are
there pheromones we create traps so make
it easier to catch them so and more
there's a they have if you ever get a
chance to hear the groups from
Pennsylvania speak they have just
amazing amounts of work that they're
doing and and I'm really helpful so is
there good news
I think they don't bite they don't sting
and they're not structural pests and
they're not here yet those are all good
those are all points of good news but I
think there's even more so there are
some things that will eat them now when
you look at the numbers it's very
unlikely that you're going to have a
good biological control for that many
insects in one place have something eat
them all but there are some that are
being fed on so anyone that's gone I
suspect is that that helps not laying
eggs there is some biological control
they found that they paired the egg
parasitoid for gypsy moth actually was
found infesting spotted lantern fly eggs
and they've got two additional ones from
China that are in quarantine for
potential release but what's something
about these egg masses that you notice
it looks different yes tell if you've
been paying attention yep yep so they
lay eggs one in rows that's how they lay
them is there something missing there's
no mud so once they're covered with mud
they're less likely to be attacked by an
egg parasitoid so this is a little wasp
it lays its egg into the egg it lays its
egg into the inside the egg of the
spotted lantern fly so they don't always
get them all covered but most of them
are so again that has some potential and
they found I think
levels of maybe 20% infestation but not
enough to give you good control these
are my favorite though not that I know
but that's a good point he was asking if
there's been any study of the of the mud
and the chemical composition of the mud
and so whether or not that's actually
repelling the insects or it's just a
physical process but they can't lay an
egg through it I think all of that is up
for grabs now there's research also
going on in Korea and in China they're
under control because they've got the
national enemies and so this is a work
and actually this is some of the work
that's being done and it Cornell is on
the biological biological or intima
pathogenic fungi actually so
the first one is Bavaria bastiana so you
can see a nicely fuzzy adult there so
it's infected with the fungus and from
what I know about malaria bassiano
because it is one of the one of the
pathogens that we use in greenhouse
production so it's currently being
produced commercially so you can
actually buy it and apply it in some
insects they shed their skins too fast
and so they kind of Slough it off so
they're not infected this has got a long
period of development and so I think
it's one where it actually can be
controlled and you can get some killing
of the insect with the Bavaria bus
Asiata so it just infects the the body
and kills the insect this one is my
favorite though this Beko a major and
it's native they found it being infected
in Pennsylvania so you notice this one
has its wings outspread and you also can
maybe see there are little fungal
strands that attach it to that leaf so
the fungus infects the insect it
actually makes it climb up higher than
normal so now it's above at the
population below causes it to open its
wings and attaches it to the plant with
these little fungal strands so it
doesn't fall off so there's a rain of
spores falling down on the ones on the
adults below but it's pretty amazing to
be that that's what the fungus can do to
the insect so so that one again looks
like that's native but not commercially
available so it has some potential so
they're actually trying spraying and
spraying a very bossy ana to see if they
can get control but the Beco and they
have to do more work on so the other
thing that has some potential good news
is so the adults will die with the cold
the eggs survive but there's a something
they're looking at the concept of
growing degree days many people know
what growing degree days are few so the
idea of you need a certain amount of
temperature to go through the stages of
development of the insect and if there's
not enough temperature and not enough
heat units they won't go all the way
through development so there's some
indication that that in parts of New
York State at any rate there are not
enough growing degree days for the
insect to complete its life cycle and
that might halt so you'll have either
fewer or no eggs laid so that's a good
sign for us and they don't really know
exactly they think I belong the lakes is
is actually a good place for the insects
five Adirondacks not so much but even
there's some type of the southern tears
not so good
fortunately we grow a lot of grapes and
apples up around the lake so in terms of
production that's a problem
so I think that's everything that the
Haag have so again I love their
advertising necessary I don't think you
can squash them all that easily maybe
that's a but I'm happy to answer
questions if I can
I'll be nice to Genevan I'm gonna ask
Geneva first Geneva do you have any
questions all right does anyone have
questions here yes now I have to think
of another one for the next time I give
a summary never will forget I was
curious if you're hearing reports from
Pennsylvania lots of agronomics damage
like is there indeed lots of agronomic
damage so they are doing lots of
pesticide spraying not just for the
agronomic damage but also for the
landscape issues and and so where
they've seen the most damage that I've
heard sorry question again have they
seen economic damage in Pennsylvania
where they've seen the most is in grapes
and hops they keep talking about hops
but I haven't seen pictures like the one
with the grape with a vineyard where you
can actually see the plants are dead
and the apples you know I guess you know
those apples the fruits not affected but
if you were someone harvesting my hand
out in there with that many insects and
that much go around I'm even if you know
even if the apples are fine you may have
to now do washing or other things in
terms of getting the honeydew in the
city mold off them so I don't think they
have I haven't I have not seen great
information on other plant damage and I
think a lot of it is again to me if you
look at those little thing we said you
could find them on basil they've got
such a big mouth parts they go right
through the stems of basil you think and
they probably suck it dry pretty quickly
so I was kind of surprised to see some
of those more herbaceous things on the
list yep so in addition to the two
pathogens that you showed us are there
other natural predators in the native
range of the insect so the question is
are there other predators or other
biological control organisms in the
native range yes so those two little
wasps that they were bringing in that
are under quarantine that they're
studying now
those are both from China and we don't
have them but of course it's not a fast
process then because you have to bring
them in and test them on all sorts of
things to make sure that they're not
going to feed on anything that we
actually want or damage anything else
that's native here so the fact that they
found the one that feeds that the egg
parasitoid of gypsy moth is surprising
they're not related but so maybe it's a
wasp it's like there's an egg we can we
can figure out how to to Paris at eyes
it but so and then whether or not there
are other death aphanitic
or fungi or other things like that that
they might bring in I haven't heard of
anything but those two that they're
working someone had a question back
there yeah the negative range how cold
is it like to go to New York so I don't
know if the question was in the native
range how cold is it compared to New
York I don't know the absolute answer on
that certainly I've seen maps where they
see where they think it's going to it
could survive and it you know once
you're getting up much farther than New
York State it's - it looks like they've
got it as too cold but it may well be
that it's not the temperature that it's
not a temperature that's killing the
eggs and I don't know the absolute
temperature for killing the eggs my
think my thought is that it's quite low
which is unfortunate I'd like to kill
the eggs any other questions
yep I mean Korea's not that far from
China why has it only been very recently
that then that's also a good question
and I don't know that it's through all
of China I should go and look there is a
map that they have that's at least the
proposed distribution throughout the
world and yes so especially if it's
moving on things like stone so if
there's trade between the two places you
would think that that would be an easy
way for it to get there and why I didn't
get there until 2014 I heard about then
- I don't know I'm gonna have to go look
that up seems like the native range is
more like Vietnam from whatever have you
yeah so maybe it's farther so
any other questions do you know anything
about crisper and spotted lantern fly
other than stuff that no not
specifically with this but it's being
counted as the Oh save us a haul but
this is more of a comment rather than a
question along highways there are rest
stops and things like that and we're
going to have observation posts you know
whatever they might be I I look at rest
stops I think that's where they're put I
think that I put anyone there in it for
the trucks at the wing stations yeah
there are very frequently
I noticed Tree of Heaven growing around
freeway exchanges you know the ridges
and things so that would both be maybe a
place to concentrate eradication efforts
although perhaps not in Brooklyn because
this is the tree grows in Brooklyn right
also maybe have concentrated scouting
efforts where you have these sequential
satellite yes and they may well be doing
that in Pennsylvania but I and I think
they're also doing it in New York
and yes the concept of because Tree of
Heaven is kind of a trash tree in a way
and it ends up and it spreads and you
see a lot of it along roadways and so
forth we did a program down in
Westchester about the time when seeds
were out and it looked like everywhere
we drove all the way along the roads
it's all Tree of Heaven it because it's
a little bit hard to kill that makes
that also means that people aren't
controlling it and it's areas where
people aren't doing much management
you're absolutely right so if you can
use Tree of Heaven in the areas where
you think you might see it as it's
moving outside of the zone it's in now
certainly scouting and using those trees
as trap trees and places to treat with
request society is a great way to do it
they're also doing a lot of trapping in
fact they they have sticky traps that
they're using and they found that they
actually had to put cages over them
because they were getting other things
like birds even stuck to the sticky trap
so now they're trying to make the wire
mesh so that the spotted lentor fly
which actually goes up and down the
trunk to some extent when they're young
that would they'll get stuck in other
things won't but so you could do the
trapping and other things and that
you're absolutely right makes sense to
do them places
vehicles are going to stop in places
that are going to have Tree of Heaven to
make it easy on yourself what's the plan
for longer than it takes now yeah yes
yes there's a lot of for them to feed on
so yeah I heard about you Matt this
issue and I just wondering because
everywhere right so it'd be nice if we
had very rarely and they had to be there
would make it easier to use that as a
management a management tool but because
they're everywhere and they're in places
that people aren't really looking it
makes it a little bit harder to use as
and as a perfect management tool early
on and I don't remember exactly there
where it was I saw a video that was a
building and there there were piles of
dead ones along sidewalks
somebody else is nodding and I don't
know if they even know why they died but
just the numbers were amazing and and it
was clearly in an urban area they've got
you could go online you can find bars
that have competitions for how many you
could SWAT with us
slice water I've seen actually they made
beer coasters and wine coasters that are
to promote knowing what spotted lantern
fly is and getting rid of it and
contacting the Pennsylvania Department
of Agriculture as I say I've found like
maybe it's a non welcome mat a welcome
mat with a spotted Lantern fly on it and
get socks with us people are making
jewelry out of real ones so people are
taking it as taking that on the
challenge and and but I think people if
you look at the house where the steps
that were coated and everything else we
don't need anything else that's going to
convince people that they don't want to
go outside and and to me like if you're
standing under a maple tree there was
someone doing a report and they're
standing under our maple tree and
they've got an umbrella and I realized
oh that's the honeydew dripping that
they're trying to avoid so that's
another that whole issue of homeowners
and tourists and everything else is I
think they're thinking and I don't think
we've counted what's the cost so we
don't want them so please don't bring
them so I tell all my girls
you do not be want to be the place where
they say oh this is where the population
started so even if your plant is not a
host be careful so any other questions
if you said grapes and Atlantis or the -
yeah so wild grapes right and also most
the plants that there seem to be using
our Sun webbing class so oh that's an
interesting point I don't know yeah
that's a good point so Nina's saying is
that they plants on the list tend to be
Sun loving plants and whether or not you
wouldn't find them in shady areas as
much I don't know the answer to that and
I haven't seen anybody talk about that
but as I say that I think we're still
even though I mean that's six years and
it's been in Pennsylvania and certainly
you're still figuring things out so and
then there's even in terms of the map
you know people don't want to have their
state put on the map so they don't want
have their County put on the map so
they're trying to even get that yes is
there any role for n-doped pesticides
biologically based pesticides yes so so
the question is if there's any role for
systemic pesticides and yes what they
tend to use when they're using those
three of heaven as trap trees is they're
actually using a systemic insecticide in
those so when the insects feed on it
they'll die and that's what they're
looking at primarily because again
trying to spray something and get good
contact over that number of insects when
they move around so much a systemic is a
much better idea and again you can get
away with you can use less pesticide and
get more effect and have it be really
spa treatment and in a controlled in a
controlled sort of application which
from IPM point of view we like
yes trap that was more attractive to the
insect and we average one movie latest
yes and make it look like a big spotted
land why so exciting could you get
something that's more attractive than
the average car just sitting out there
screaming trap right trap it's not well
they're looking for pheromones and that
so if you can find something that would
be even if it's not enough to trap them
to control him but it's enough to tell
you that they're around and that's why
some having something like a spud
lantern fly sniffing dog they did have
one situation where the dog kept
pointing it you know saying it's here
and they couldn't find it and they did
finally find it inside the grill of the
vehicle and so they're well trained but
so yeah something like that where it's a
faster made a faster means of doing it
because thinking about trying to clean
off every vehicle that's going down the
highway route 15 into into New Yorker
and 81 into New York is just you know
almost an impossible idea so having
something that could could check more
easily would be great so left I'm sure
somebody's working on it thank you
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu